[Music]
salmon poached the next job is making
the like tarragon mayonnaise tarragon
mayonnaise with the difference first of
all can make it to start off with one
egg yolk
little bit of heat in there teaspoon of
mustard a little splash of tarragon
vinegar in whisk that first nice big
blue whisk and then when the bus starts
moving get your cloth open it up just go
around and keep it on there that's not
going anywhere now yeah
what we want to do first is with nice
and thick so he can take the oil with
one hand sunflower oil and the other
thumb over the end of the bottle tip it
upside down slowly drip feed the oil in
whisk whisk whisk drip drip drip and
stop whisk and change hands that way
that is getting tired whisk whisk whisk
drizzle the sunflower oil in stop once
you've got that nice base you can add
the oil quicker it's so easy delicious
when it's reach that luscious thick
consistency add a squeeze of lemon juice
and that's your basic mayonnaise done
but I'm gonna thin it down with water
because I want it much much lighter
almost like a vinaigrette which is
perfect for salmon lease was
still nice and creamy now that chopped
tarragon the aniseed takes work really
well with the eggs and lemon zest to
liven it up
and now the seasoning always at the end
salt pepper I just mix that around no
beautiful it's got the texture of a
custard almost like a lemon curd it's
incredibly rich it just falls off the
spoon its traditional to use boiled eggs
and salad nicoise but I'm gonna do mine
differently cuddle the eggs first put
some water on to heat then coat espresso
cups or similar ovenproof containers
with butter next season each cup with
pepper and lime with a couple of basil
leaves which gives the eggs a lovely
herby note with a season it but the
classic Nicoise garnish anchovies we
just roll that round like a little ring
and sit there at the bottom of the basil
then cracking your eggs every little
component going on that plate makes a
big difference
taking it up to that little extra
special level place the espresso cups in
a bath of boiling water and baking the
oven for about eight minutes so the
yolks are still soft and creamy
where the eggs in the oven it's time to
bring the final components of the
Nicoise together